pendant cette première demi-heure
sénateur communiste du Nord
vice-président de la commission des
finances on va parler lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
évidemment la réforme des retraites le
gouvernement ne se projette pas dans
l'idée d'une mobilisation massive c'est
ce qu'a dit hier Olivier Véran à la
sortie du Conseil des ministres
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
déclaration bah je crois qu'il le la
souhaite pas évidemment il l'a craint
cette mobilisation parce que on sent
bien qu'il y a une espèce d'alignement
des planètes là un front syndical uni
quoi pas vu depuis plusieurs années une
opinion vous l'avez rappelé
majoritairement opposée à cette réforme
des retraites une majorité de gens y
compris prêts à se mobiliser sous quelle
forme dans quelle proportion nul ne le
sait on n'appuie pas sur un bouton pour
déclencher un mouvement mais il faut
vraiment que les gens se interviennent
se mêlent de cette affaire qui est
déterminante sur le choix de société
dans lequel on veut vivre et donne leur
avis concrètement ça veut pas dire de
manière violente mais de manière massive
déterminée et claire pour que on ne
touche pas et on ne met pas en péril ce
système système de retraite par
répartition né au lendemain la Seconde
Guerre mondiale vous pensez réussir à
mobiliser
fortement puisque c'est l'objectif des
syndicats c'est l'objectif des
particules
c'est pas une personne qui va décider
seul encore une fois c'est pas une
affaire de presse bouton il faut aller
aux explications parce que franchement
je trouve les arguments du gouvernement
un peu faibla mettre en avant la
démographie le caractère inéluctable de
cette réforme les autres pays d'Europe
l'ont fait et alors on a un modèle
social en France qui est le produit
d'une histoire de lutte combat dire
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y aurait plus
l'argent pour financer ce modèle on a de
quoi en argument contester cette vérité
qui reposent sur un système par
répartition c'est à dire que ce sont les
actifs qui payent pour les retraités et
il y a de moins en moins d'actifs pour
de plus en plus de retraités pour vous
il n'y a pas de réforme nécessaire non
parce qu'il y a un paramètre qu'on ne
met jamais sur la table on nous dit
l'espérance de vie augmente etc il y a
un paramètre qu'on met jamais sur la
table c'est celui de la richesse dans ce
pays produit j'ai regardé un peu
l'histoire économique de la France et 30
dernières années vous connaissez le
niveau du PIB en 90 c'est pas le
moyen-âge il y a une trentaine d'années
là il était à 1000 milliards d'euros le
PIB de la France cette année en 2022
pratiquement 2500 milliards d'euros donc
on a produit de la richesse de manière
croissante régulière cette 30 dernières
années qu'on nous dise aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a pas les moyens de financer ce
système de retraite il faudra regarder
plutôt les conséquences des choix qui
ont été faits par les gouvernements
successifs qui ont amené à la réduction
des recettes de ce système de retraite
on n'est pas dans un problème de
dépenses excessive on est dans un
problème de recettes qui manque par des
choix qui ont été fait ces dernières
années il y a aussi alors évidemment il
y a le report de l'âge légal de départ
dans ce texte est l'accélération de
l'augmentation du nombre d'années mais
il y a aussi des mesures pour la
pénibilité pour les carrières longues
pour l'emploi des seniors pour les
carrières HS est-ce que on balayant ce
texte vous ne rejetez pas aussi ces
mesures non mais ça c'est la petite
pommade pour faire passer le le
bah oui c'est les petites mesures
ponctuelles fichiers là pour rassurer
l'opinion mais sans fondamentalement
remettre en question les choix de fonds
de ce système de retraite par
répartition il faut pas se laisser
tromper abuser par des petites
mesurettes ici ou là qui serait concédé
par ce gouvernement c'est un système une
réforme globale qu'il faut vraiment
rejeter fondamentalement
le 19 janvier à notre place les
syndicats on leur action propre les élus
les partis politiques les associations
les retraités eux-mêmes enfin voilà ça
c'est une affaire qui concerne toute la
nation quoi mais chacun dans son rôle et
chacun a sa place donc oui bien sûr le
29 je serai dans la rue à Lille
j'imagine qu'il y aura un rassemblement
comme partout en France et le 21 puisque
la France insoumise à peine elle aussi à
se mobiliser à marcher contre cette
réforme des retraites le 21 janvier là
aussi vous serez au côté de la France
tous ces rendez-vous de s'oppose pas il
s'accumulent on peut imaginer que le
mouvement en une le sait comment il va
se dérouler mais on peut imaginer que
dans les semaines qui viennent ils
prennent de l'ampleur et qu'il gonflent
donc tous ces rendez-vous doivent
s'additionner et agréger le mouvement
pour arriver vraiment à un rapport de
force très conséquent dans ce pays
est-ce que pour vous je sais que les
républicains sont plutôt partants pour
voter cette réforme est-ce que du coup
la bataille se jouera plus dans la rue
qu'au Parlement selon vous les deux
batailles encore une fois ça ne s'oppose
pas ça se complète mais le Parlement ne
suffira pas effectivement on voit bien
déjà les tractations les accords mais
c'est pas une surprise je l'avais dit
ici on s'était vu au moment du PLF en
novembre que déjà les républicains
chaque année dépose leur amendement qui
vise à reporter l'âge de la retraite
donc c'est la Fabien sur le fond alors
ils sont en train de discuter vous
comprenez qu'ils se tiennent ce texte je
sais pas une surprise c'était prévu
gouvernement essaie de dégager une
majorité politique à l'Assemblée mais
après il faut avoir une majorité dans le
pays et c'est pas si simple on peut pas
ne pas tenir compte de l'état de
l'opinion et de son engagement et
comment vous allez mener la bataille au
Parlement des explications démonter
l'argumentaire qu'on nous oppose
argumentaire un peu simplicité mécaniste
pour démontrer qu'il y a de l'argent
pour financer ce système de retraite qui
peut être préservé qu'il n'y a pas
d'urgence que on a d'autres moyens de de
le préserver il y a pas urgence
d'ailleurs les deux derniers exercices
ont été excédentaires c'est le corps qui
le montre bien donc les chiffres il va y
avoir une bataille de chiffres donc
c'est argument contre argument un beau
débat il faudrait un débat à la hauteur
de celui de 2005 sur le traité européen
que tout le monde s'en en parle il
faudra un référendum aussi sur cette
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas référendum
c'est pas de mauvaise idée que les gens
tranchent une fininée qu'ils expriment
leur avis ça semble être le cas et au
bout d'un référendum après un bon débat
politique de fond franchement ça aurait
de l'allure alors vous demandez un débat
politique de fond la France insoumise
elle prévoit de déposer des milliers
d'amendements ce qui du coup empêcherait
un débat vous comprenez cette stratégie
pas forcément c'est pas forcément la
plus efficace après que qui est des
amendements bon c'est le c'est le
travail des parlementaires on est bien
d'accord mais encore une fois la
bataille de milliers d'amendements par
parlementaires
et donc on pourrait pas aller au bout du
débat mais il faut surtout s'appuyer sur
un mouvement social fort conscient et
déterminé voilà
évidemment on va parler de ce qui se
passe au Sénat et de ce qui s'est passé
hier notamment puisqu'il y a eu un débat
ici dans l'hémicycle du Sénat sur la
lutte contre l'évasion et la fraude
fiscale sujet que vous suivez tout
particulièrement on va voir les temps
forts de cette séance avec Audrey
viettaz
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour et Audrey
hier la lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale était donc au centre
des débats du Sénat à la demande de la
commission des finances oui et ça a été
l'occasion de faire le bilan de la
dernière loi en la matière elle date de
2018 l'occasion aussi de mettre en
lumière les travaux de la commission des
finances et de la mission d'information
qui s'est achée cet automne à ce sujet
avec des constats et des préconisations
dont on a reparlé hier soir alors sur la
loi de 2018 le bilan semble plutôt bon
d'après le rapporteur Russon l'arsenal
de lutte contre afro des plus tôt rôle
buste en France est-ce que souligne
plusieurs ONG je vous propose d'écouter
le sénateur Antoine Lefebvre qui évoque
les résultats de la mission
d'information à ce sujet leur conclusion
font état d'un gain d'efficacité des
instruments affectés au contrôle fiscal
et ainsi d'une progression des montants
recouvrés sur les cinq dernières années
10,6 milliards d'euros en 2021 contre
7,7 3 années plus tôt
autre point positif de la loi de 2018
alors le Sénat concrètement le ministère
des Finances a maintenant l'obligation
de transmettre certains dossiers au
procureur de la République même sans
plaindre préalable de l'administration
fiscale évidemment ça a permis de
multiplier les dossiers mais il reste
des trous dans la raquette le premier
qui a été souligné par de nombreux
sénateurs et par la mission
d'information c'est qu'on a du mal à
estimer le montant général de la fraude
et des recouvrements et c'est un
problème écouté
au moment où les chiffres se multiplient
dans le débat public parfois un peu à
tort à travers nous avons besoin
d'évaluation
méthodologiquement plus étayée et plus
robuste et il faudrait pouvoir estimer
monsieur le ministre quel est le montant
des droits fondés fraudé pardon que
l'administration parvient finalement à
récupérer 10 20 30 % en plus personne à
ce stade ne peut véritablement le dire
cette impératif a d'ailleurs donné lieu
à un amendement accepté dans le dernier
projet de loi de finance malgré le 49-3
et ça ça vaut la peine d'être souligné
il a été aussi question de la fraude à
la TVA oui c'est l'une des principales
fraudes et ça représente tout de même 23
milliards d'euros de manque à gagner
chaque année première mesure qu'on pour
lutter contre cela et c'est à
l'initiative du Sénat là encore les
compétences des officiers fiscaux
judiciaires seront étendues aux
escroqueries à la TVA le ministre des
comptes publics Gabriel Attal a aussi
annoncé un nouveau chantier d'envergure
sur ce point là il y a un chantier qui
me semble absolument majeur qui est
celui de la facturation électronique
inter-entreprise qui a été adopté par le
Parlement il y a plusieurs années
maintenant la réforme va commencer à
entrer en vigueur à partir de 2024 c'est
une réforme majeure en termes techniques
c'est de la même ampleur que le
prélèvement à la source on en parlera
probablement moins puisque ça concerne
pas tous les Français immédiatement mais
les entreprises mais croyez bien qu'on y
travaille d'arrache-pied pour anticiper
les choses pour que ce soit évidemment
simples pour les entreprises c'est pour
ça que l'entrée en vigueur sera
progressive il me semble que le pays qui
a mis en place en premier en Europe en
tout cas dans les pays comparables cette
réforme c'est l'Italie qui dès les
premières années a pu bénéficier de
plusieurs milliards d'euros de TVA
recouvré qu'il ne l'était pas auparavant
et ensuite il y a un effet
comportemental évidemment des
entreprises dans leur déclaration
vous avez aussi beaucoup parlé de la
lutte contre les paradis fiscaux car
dans les faits on se rend compte que
même au sein de l'Union européenne avec
le Luxembourg il y a donc des pays le
Luxembourg qui abrite des sociétés offre
sur certaines sont françaises première
question est-ce que vous trouvez que la
France en fait assez est-ce qu'on en
fait assez aussi au niveau de l'Union
européenne parce que c'est vrai qu'on se
souvient de Nicolas Sarkozy qui a lancé
la fin des paradis fiscaux on en est
loin oui on en est très loin je veux
dire depuis cette annonce de territoire
de Monsieur Sarkozy en 2009 les paradis
fiscaux c'est terminé j'ai fait le
compte on a eu 15 affaires révélées par
la presse les lanceurs d'alerte
notamment
depuis Cahuzac en 2013 qui a fait un mal
considérable cette république qu'on a eu
par le respect Panama papers etc à
chaque fois les mêmes constats des
chiffres astronomiques une
sophistication extraordinaire et puis
une grande hypocrisie au sein l'Union
européenne effectivement le Luxembourg
qui n'est pas reconnu par l'Union
européenne comme un paradis fiscal vous
avez rappelé cette affaire à révélé par
le monde Open luxe février 2021 55000
sociétés offshore détenant ensemble 6500
milliards d'euros et parmi ces 55000 en
tête de liste les Français 17000
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ces données
est-ce qu'on a récupéré les choses et ce
qu'on a investigué est-ce qu'on a les
moyens de le faire voilà donc le
Luxembourg c'est une anomalie terrible
et puis d'autres États qu'on pourrait
citer Malte Chypre les Pays-Bas
notamment et au sein de l'Union
européenne sur les sujets fiscaux il y a
une règle qu'il faudrait changer c'est
l'arrêt de l'unanimité vous voyez sur
les 27 États membres un seul pourrait
s'opposer à la volonté des des 26 autres
pour avancer véritablement pour établir
une véritable liste paradis fiscaux donc
il faut sortir de l'hypocrisie d'où le
langage nommer les choses pour attaquer
la racine du problème
non c'est une volonté politique je l'ai
dit hier à la fin de mon propos sans
volonté politique unanime ou moins
majoritaire vos seniors européenne il y
a des règles à changer il faut vraiment
s'attaquer à ça quand on voit dans
quelle situation nos finances publiques
sont parce que on se prive de 80
milliards d'euros de recettes chaque
année en France 1000 milliards d'euros à
l'Union européenne quand est-ce qu'on
s'att faire ça tous ensemble c'est
l'intérêt de tous de tous les états de
toutes les sociétés non moi je suis un
optimiste convaincu il y a une bataille
amenée mais il faut l'amener et ne pas
céder un pouce et puis pénaliser les
choses pas négocier l'impôt avec
McDonald's des Google comme ça se passe
aujourd'hui ils ont fauté ils ont triché
ils doivent payer et être pénalisés ça
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui il y a des
systèmes dans la loi française la
convention judiciaire d'intérêt public
la comparution préalable pour la
responsabilités là c'est RPC c'est un
système de plaid découpable à
l'anglo-saxonne qui permet aux gens de
dire au côté je vous fais un chèque mais
vous ne mettez pas en justice
franchement le contribuable qui entend
ça c'est inacceptable c'est pas
entendable il faut changer ses règles là
et ça ça relève du droit français c'est
à nous le décider justement c'est un
point que vous avez évoqué hier face au
ministre il vous a répondu oui mais ça
nous permet de recouvrir l'argent plus
rapidement d'éviter les appels les
procès en longueur et souvent des peines
moins lourdes qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez ce
discours déjà monsieur Cazeneuve en son
temps et avant lui disait on préfère
aller sur cette procédure-là ça permet
de récupérer un peu d'argent et parce
qu'en justice parfois c'est très long en
phase de nous on est des gens très
costauds des avocats très pointus et on
est pas sûr de gagner au bout donc ça
veut dire qu'on capitule ça veut dire
que le politique capitule par rapport à
ces fraudes-là moi je suis de la vie que
l'État réaffirme sa volonté politique et
se fasse respecter par ses grands
groupes qui ne jouent pas la règle et
qui pénalise les démocraties et et les
États dans leur budget non il faut pas
capituler il faut dire les choses et
combattre frontalement le système parce
qu'il s'agit bien d'un système c'est une
industrie d'évasion fiscale c'est pas un
dysfonctionnement d'un système
financière risé mondialisé non non c'est
un système créé la richesse et faire en
sorte qu'elle ne contribue pas au
fonctionnement de la société
un autre mot de la dernière question
parce que c'était la dernière question
Audrey parler de cette loi de 2018 la
loi de Gérald Darmanin de lutte contre
la fraude fiscale qu'est-ce qui a changé
depuis elle a été efficace cette là très
partiellement je me souviens dans les
dispositions de la loi qui est Monsieur
Darmanin prévoyait en 2018 il avait
annoncé la création d'un observatoire de
la lutte contre la fraude fiscale et un
jour il a annoncé qu'il n'avait pas été
créé l'Observatoire parce qu'il y avait
pas trouvé de président et donc j'avais
à l'époque proposé ma candidature à
titre bénévole voyez j'ai même été reçu
Monsieur Darmanin à Bercy au cinquième
étage dans son bureau et puis on en est
resté là quoi on en est resté là et
Jean-François Husson a raison dans son
intervention de pointer c'est ce que le
rapport monte qui a un problème
d'évaluation de la fraude fiscale donc
ma proposition est toujours d'actualité
l'Observatoire n'a pas été créé ça
faisait partie des mesures un peu
spectaculaires annoncées par Monsieur
Darmanin
il est au courant il le sait j'imagine
mais voilà je suis toujours
sur
à chiffrer
cette fraude fiscale déjà quelle
différence entre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale on soit bien clair j'ai toujours
en tête la citation de ce ministre
anglais de chancelet de l'échiquier
ministre des Finances des nissiés qui
disait la différence entre l'évasion et
la fraude fiscale et les dans
l'épaisseur de un mur de prison oui il
avait dit ça donc c'est vraiment tenu
hein on est dans les choses un peu
légales parce que le droit le permet
donc il y a parfois des abus de droit
franchement les deux phénomènes
contribuent à affaiblir les recettes des
états donc les deux sont condamnables il
faut arrêter de de ce pseudo
à évaluer de combien l'État est pénalise
dans le rapport qu'on avait fait en 2000
en 2012 on était arrivé à chier de 36
milliards il y a les syndicats SUD
finance qui estiment à 80 100 milliards
le montant donc il y a vraiment besoin
d'une évaluation en tout cas ce n'est
pas marginale ce n'est pas mineur c'est
supérieur à ce que l'impôt société
rapporte dans notre dans notre budget
voilà d'où la nécessité de construire un
outil l'Observatoire avec des ONG des
syndicalistes des des spécialistes des
parlementaires des financiers des gens
qui ont une autre vision éthique de la
finance qui pourrait ensemble travailler
avec tous les outils dont on dispose à
chiffrer le mieux possible mais on est
sur des montants absolument
astronomiques
mais est-ce que aussi pour les
particuliers les sanctions plus sévères
bah oui je pense enfin je sais pas c'est
la fraude des particuliers c'est pas la
plus massive mais néanmoins elle est
aussi dommageable au niveau du
consentement à l'impôt mais franchement
pour les ceux qui sont convaincus
d'évasion fiscales ça se passe pas pas
mal quoi un petit bracelet électronique
et puis ça va on va passer à l'actualité
dans nos régions on va aller du côté de
Marseille retrouver les hauts purghad
bonjour Léo merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous président et directeur éditorial du
Journal La Marseillaise et les hauts
vous nous proposez un dossier sur les
aides aux entreprises pour faire face à
la flambée des prix de l'énergie
oui dans notre région la Direction des
finances publiques décliner les mesures
qui sont prises par l'État pour venir en
aide à ces entreprises qui sont
effectivement
étranglées les entreprises artisanales
les PME pas seulement les boulangers
mais évidemment ils sont au cœur des
discussions depuis
quelques semaines déjà on fait réagir
les principaux intéressés leur
représentants et pour eux le compte n'y
est pas du tout ou pas tout à fait selon
leur approche ce que je voulais demander
au sénateur Boké c'est ce qu'il pensait
lui de ses aides qui sont assez loin
finalement du quoi qu'il en coûte mis en
oeuvre pendant la pandémie et qui a
permis à des grandes entreprises de
réaliser aujourd'hui des super profits
et puis je voulais savoir aussi si à
l'image de ce qui se passait à
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat il y
avait une commission qui traitait de la
question de la perte de la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays parce que on
voit bien que cette question est au cœur
du sujet
question importante effectivement sur
les aides aux entreprises vont d'abord
je voudrais rappeler que chaque année
tout est confondu la République
française accorde de l'ordre de 160
milliards d'euros d'aide au monde
économique ça c'est un premier élément
et s'agissant de la crise énergétique du
moment là je voyais dans la presse mardi
les annonces par rapport aux dividendes
distribués au titre de 2022 aux
actionnaires on est à un chiffre de 80
milliards on n'est pas encore sorti de
la crise on est même au cœur de la crise
ces chiffres s'étalent comme ça dans des
de manière indécente on est face à ça
et vous dit il faut pas d'aide ou il
faut des aides avec des contreparties il
faudrait au moins un minimum une
transparence et certaines aides qu'il
faudrait remettre en question très
nettement je pense au crédit d'impôt le
crédit d'impôt recherche par exemple on
n'est pas convaincu de l'utilité de
l'efficacité de ce système c'est souvent
utilisé par des grands groupes comme un
moyen d'optimiser l'impôt donc ça c'est
absolument condamnable il faut la
transparence et puis revoir certaines
aides incontestablement et souvenez-vous
du débat qu'il y a eu du PLF Monsieur le
Maire à l'époque il savait pas ce que
c'était que les super profits ben je
l'invite à lire la presse cette semaine
il va comprendre ce que c'est ça existe
cette réalité les actionnaires en
bénéficient largement et là on a des PME
des boulangers des artisans qui s'en
sortent plus les collectivités on pourra
en parler également
on paye aussi ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières années la libéralisation du
marché d'énergie au sein d'Union
européenne c'est ça le fond c'est pas la
guerre en Ukraine qui a une petite
incidence bien sûr mais le fond c'est
pas ça aujourd'hui on a obligé EDF à
vendre à ses concurrents le
kilowatt-heure à 42 euros et ses
concurrents le revendent à 280 au PME
aujourd'hui qui n'arrive plus à faire
face à la flambée du coup de l'énergie
il faut revenir fondamentalement sur sur
cette logique là l'énergie doit pas être
une marchandise c'est un bien
indispensable au même titre que l'eau
que l'on consomme les uns et les autres
quoi l'énergie ça sert à tout le monde
ça s'est rien compris à l'économie aux
particuliers voilà il faut sortir le
marché de l'énergie de la loi du marché
il y avait une deuxième question de Léo
sur la souveraineté oui alors la
souveraineté effectivement d'ailleurs on
a été à l'origine un débat le groupe
communiste au Sénat avec Fabien gay
notre ami Fabien gay qui a présenté
notre provision de résolution et sur ce
sur ce sujet elle n'a pas été votée donc
il y a eu un débat dans l'hémicycle mais
il faut aller encore une fois jusqu'au
fond des choses et remettre en question
la logique qui est de la matrice
européenne ça vient de là le départ
l'ouverture du marché libre concurrence
on paye ça donc on a on porte ça
régulièrement il faut revenir à un
marché réglementé il faut marcher des
tarifs réglementés il faut revenir à une
EDF nationalisée véritablement voilà de
faire en sorte
l'État est actionnaire mais on dit qu'on
va augmenter enfin on va revenir à 100%
de de propriétés publiques mais c'est la
logique même qu'il faut la loi nomme de
2010 qui oblige EDF à vendre son énergie
moins cher à ses concurrent enfin on
marche complètement sur la tête là il
faut remettre en cause ce principe là la
loi nom il faut revenir dessus et la
reine également est-ce qu'il faut aussi
travailler sur notre capacité à produire
nos propres besoins d'électricité
puisque le Sénat va examiner la semaine
prochaine la loi sur le nucléaire est-ce
que ça aussi c'est un sujet il y a des
divergences à gauche là-dessus vous êtes
plus favorable
à gauche le nucléaire enfin il y a 15 20
ans nous étions exportateurs d'énergie
en Europe et on avait l'énergie la moins
chère en Europe mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé entre temps on est une situation
complètement dingue donc oui nous sommes
nous favorables nucléaires il faut
aujourd'hui je crois que ce soit 166% de
notre énergie qui est d'origine
nucléaire parce qu'il y a des problèmes
de maintenance etc donc il faut revenir
à une capacité plus grande diversifier
les ressources énergétiques bien sûr il
faut le sur le soleil l'hydrolien etc il
faut il faut diversifier le mix
énergétique mais en s'appuyant sur un
socle nucléaire important qui offre
vraiment c'est autour de 70%, il faut le
baisser ou pas non il faut il faut il
faut rester il faut rester à ce niveau
là ça ça garantit notre souveraineté et
une tarification que l'on maîtrise quoi
et c'est une énergie pilotable le
nucléaire pilotable merci
les cons à vos questions
oui je crois alors tout va bien regarde
la Une de La Marseillaise artisan et PME
étranglé malgré les aides face à la
hausse de l'énergie c'est la Une de
votre journal ce matin merci beaucoup
Léo ferguettes d'avoir été avec nous on
va parler de politique politicienne
puisque tout est politique vous me direz
que mais on a notamment parlé du retour
d'Adrien catenens hier à l'Assemblée
nationale qui a été condamnée pour
violence conjugale qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce retour du député du Nord
je pense que c'est un vrai problème ça
pose une vraie question
voilà il a été jugé il a été condamné
moi à sa place franchement j'aurais du
mal à assumer quoi je pense que j'aurais
mis fin à mes fonctions j'aurais du mal
à assumer cette situation quand il va
prendre la parole sur ces sujets ou sur
d'autres ça va lui coller à la peau
comme un sparadrap quoi il va suit
traîner ça comme un boulet
c'est un cas de conscience mais
sincèrement moi à titre personnel je
n'assumerai pas une telle situation vous
êtes élu du même département est-ce
qu'on vous en parle dans votre
département quel est le ressenti des
habitants
dans les deux sens parfois en termes de
soutien parfois en termes de un peu sur
la tonalité de ce que je viens de dire
c'est pas le sujet de préoccupation
numéro 1 mais ça ça a choqué ça surpris
évidemment ça a choqué profondément les
associations féministes mais pas que
plus globalement le souci de
l'exemplarité d'un parlementaire c'est
une vraie une vraie préoccupation chez
les gens l'actualité politique c'est
aussi ce vote des militants socialistes
ce soir qui doivent choisir le texte
d'orientation en vue de désigner leur
prochain en premier secrétaire est-ce
que c'est aussi l'avenir de la nuque qui
se joue dans ce vote
on partit sans doute j'imagine que c'est
dans les débats enfin j'ai vu que
c'était dans les débats chez eux comme
celles les chelou celle les partout au
sein de la gauche pour l'anus c'était un
accord électoral au législatif qui a
permis à chaque composant de la gauche
pluraliste d'exister d'avoir des des
forces au sein de l'hémicycle très bien
est-ce que ça doit devenir un projet
politique global pour ma part je suis
pas convaincu je crois que c'est pas
antinomique d'avoir des au sein de la
gauche qui sont diverses mais qui
travaillent ensemble sur des sujets là
on a parlé des retraites on pourrait
parler d'énergie des inégalités tout
cela douane et peu nous rassembler sans
difficulté mais chacun gardant son
identité propre voilà sans qu'il y ait
besoin de ce fondre dans un ensemble qui
s'appelle rénuce ou autrement voilà on
peut coopérer chacun avec nos
différences comme ça c'est fait dans
l'histoire pour tirer dans le sens du
progrès cette société chacun avec vos
candidats il y a des élections qui
arrivent des sénatoriales des
européennes chacun de regarder ses
candidats où il doit y avoir des
candidats-unis
pour ma part je pense que tout est
ouvert il faut toujours juger l'utilité
par rapport aux besoins des gens
non quelle démarche au plan national et
la plus utile au mouvement populaire
pourra gagner des avancées pour résister
et construire une autre société c'est ça
notre boussole ça doit être celle-là les
gens l'intérêt des gens
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin dans 20 minutes dans le club de
territoires on parlera des zones
affaiblissement c'était en débat au
Sénat cette semaine les plus grandes
villes françaises qui sont interdites
aux véhicules les plus polluants depuis
le 1er janvier mesure contester qu'un
vécu comme injuste par certains on en
débattra et puis on ira voir un exemple
à Rouen mais d'abord on accueillir notre
prochain invité c'est Stéphane Le folle
qui nous rejoint